meanwhile new york city demonstrating
full scale that trump was right so you
remember that time when there was a big
argument over the robert e lee statue in
charlottesville it was the subject of
that alt-right unite the right rally and
that ended of course in violence and
then there's this very controversial
press conference where trump seemed to
quasi downplay the the evils of the
white supremacist but kind of but then
walk it back but then walk and it was
all a mess right but there was one thing
trump said during that press conference
that was 100 right and the left said
this has never happened he said if you
tear down the statues of robert e lee
jefferson's next washington's next and a
lot of the left david graham in the
atlantic for example we're like no no no
no we're not going after the founders
that would be very silly after all
there's a major distinction between
people who actively fought to
make the country not exist anymore as a
country and people who established the
country and who also participated in the
sins of their time okay now i agree
there is a major distinction between
robert e lee and george washington or
between robert e lee and thomas
jefferson but you know who doesn't agree
a large swath of the left which believes
that all of these people are inherently
bad they're evil white slave holders and
therefore they must be torn down and it
doesn't matter if they established
generalized principles which led to the
foundation of the greatest republic in
the history of mankind nope all that
matters is that they lived as people in
their times and made and were involved
in sins that were fairly common at the
time doesn't mean that they weren't evil
sin is sin but it does mean
that to pretend that we are building
statues to thomas jefferson because of
his treatment of sally hemmings is
idiotic no one is building statues to
thomas jefferson because of that we're
building statues to thomas jefferson
because thomas jefferson was the author
of the declaration of independence
because thomas jefferson helped
negotiate the peace because thomas
jefferson was president of the united
states involved in louisiana purchase i
mean there are lots of reasons to build
statues to thomas jefferson generally
when you build statues to a human you're
not doing so because you are green
lighting every element of what they
believed right this is why we have
martin luther king day every martin
luther king day there's an attempt by
the left to sort of suggest that if you
buy into martin luther king as a figure
as a seminal figure in american history
this must be because you also endorse
his socialistic view of economic
redistribution that's very silly the
reason that we celebrate martin luther
king day is because martin luther king
was calling for a united states beyond
race for people to be judged as
individuals not as groups on the basis
of skin color right that is the main
takeaway when you build a statue you're
looking for the main takeaway not an
endorsement of every aspect of anybody's
life because on that basis nobody should
have a statue there's a famous section
of the talmud where there's a discussion
over whether it be better for people to
have been born or not been born it's a
big debate it's a big philosophical
debate and one side says better for
people to be born because they can
perform commandments and they can
fulfill god's will and the other side's
like not better for man not to be born
because human beings inherently sin and
they send an awful lot and they are
bound to do more bad than good
and the atonement comes down on the side
it would have been better for men not to
be born but since you are born you
better do some mitzvot you better do
some commandments okay that is the view
that you should have toward human nature
and toward building statues of people
okay when it comes to building a statue
of somebody you're not building a statue
to their sin you're building a statue to
the stuff that they did that was correct
okay but nobody seems to be able to make
this particular distinction when it
comes to the left
right if you were a sinner a grave
sinner
from 1790 this means the statue has to
come down even if you're the author of
the words that created the creed that
were foundational to not only the
creation of the united states but also
to the ending of slavery to the civil
rights movement there's a reason that
the words of thomas jefferson echo
not through the slave holding south but
echo through the free north there's a
reason that the words of the declaration
of independence are invoked by people
like frederick douglass and booker t
washington and martin luther king
there's a reason for that but apparently
not to the new york city council
which has not only no historical
perspective but no philosophical
understanding according to the new york
times for more than a hundred years a
seven foot tall statue of thomas
jefferson has towered over members of
the new york city council in their
chamber at city hall a testament to his
role as one of the nation's founding
fathers and the primary author of the
declaration of independence but for the
last two decades some black and latino
council members citing jefferson's
history as a slaveholder called for the
statute to be banished a push that
gained significant momentum in the last
year as the nation has broadly
reconsidered public monuments that can
be viewed as symbols of systemic racism
now again thomas jefferson's statutes
are not about systemic racism they're
about the words of the declaration of
independence that apply to all human
beings
okay that's the whole point the
declaration of imp the reason that
thomas jefferson was a hypocrite in his
own life is because he knew that he
wasn't upholding his own standards but
that doesn't mean that the standards
were wrong or that his articulation of
the standards was bad the articulation
of the standards is what he was being
held up to
on monday city officials voted
unanimously to remove the statue of
thomas jefferson from council chambers
but delayed a decision on where to put
it presumably we need to put up a statue
of george floyd because that is more
symbolic of the united states a career
criminal who is killed by a cop that is
much more symbolic of the united states
now
you got to notice the illogic here right
there there are george floyd statues
that are now being erected in major
cities around the united states what are
you building the statue of george floyd
do
george floyd led a mess of his life
hey put aside how he died his life was
in absolute shambles he was a mess he
was a career criminal who spent an awful
lot of time in jail he was high as a
kite when he encountered the cops on the
day of his fateful death
and you're building a statue to him why
is the statue to all of the bad things
he did in his life or is the statue
supposed to be a commemoration of what
happened to him
right so the philosophy of of how you
build a statue obviously applies to
george floyd but no longer applies to
thomas jefferson and if you're going to
talk about somebody who did more good
for the world thomas jefferson or george
floyd that is not a comparison it is
just not one person was involved in the
foundation of a country the other was a
career criminal who unfortunately died
at the hands of a cop
that is not there's no comparison there
but we're a country that says yes yes on
the statues of george floyd ixnay on the
statues of thomas jefferson good luck to
that country
signing nielsen president of the public
design commission which oversees art at
city-owned property said quote there are
700 pieces of art under our jurisdiction
we cannot make a rash decision that will
set a precedent for the other 699 pieces
of artwork that may also have challenges
from people or other groups of people
the relocation of the statue requested
by the council's black latino and asian
caucus was expected to be a fate
accompli
i i just i why the asian was thomas
jefferson like super anti-asian i didn't
know about it okay anyway an agreement
was already in place to relocate the
statutes to the new york historical
society a crate had been ordered to
house the statue during the move
the unexpected delay angered some black
and latino lawmakers they're not super
worried about the rising rates of murder
in the city or the poverty and
homelessness in the city of new york but
they are deeply worried that this statue
is in a room with them
because the statue is going to do
something to them it's like the end of
don giovanni is going to emerge from
hell to drag them down or something
there have been various attempts to
remove the statue two decades ago a call
to banish the statue gained detention
but it went nowhere because we weren't
complete idiots 20 years ago
adrian adams councilwoman from queens
said jefferson embodies some of the most
shameful parts of our country's history
yeah so does like all of history
i i'm sorry to break it to adrian adams
but all of human history is replete with
suffering and
i evil
i'm sure her text messages are replete
with some bad stuff like are we really
going to play this game
this is not a game that is worth playing
opposition to removing the statue began
to surface in recent days a group of 17
historians sent a letter on monday to
the panel suggesting the statue stayed
city hall and simply be relocated to the
governor's room where it was originally
housed for the most of the 19th century
a daily news editorial on monday also
questioned at the move
removal of the removal is a very simple
solution that will erase the debate said
raymond lavertu a historian at the
rothermere american institute at the
university of oxford
although jefferson was massively flawed
he added his ideas on equality should be
grappled with daily well yes
but again
trump was right trump was correct
okay the left seems it's bound and
determined like bound and determined to
justify all of the worst expectations of
the right so the right's like if you
guys take down that robert e lee statue
you'll probably go out for washington
and liberals like nope nah nah nah and
then the left's like no absolutely we
will absolutely 100 we will
we already have the public design
commission voting to remove the theodore
roosevelt statue at the entrance of the
american museum of natural history
despite theodore roosevelt's
contributions to that field
and they also have been talking about
removing other statues as well
it's pretty incredible stuff really
great but you know what this philosophy
is alive and well inside the bible
administration so jennifer granholm
who is the secretary of energy
jennifer granholm she was on national tv
and she was talking about communist
china
and she literally said we don't have the
moral authority to call it communist
china you have to understand tearing
down jefferson is part and parcel of an
idea about tearing down america and
suggesting that america on the world
stage has no place this is part and
parcel of what we talked about yesterday
the getting rid of the truth justice in
the american way slogan from superman
the left is intent on the notion that
america is actually morally decrepit
there's something deeply wrong morally
with the united states america does not
deserve to have a place on the world
stage we have to fix all our we have to
make america into utopia in order for us
to be proud of ourselves and the way you
make america into utopia is by sinking
into a socialist morass and being
incredibly surrender oriented in foreign
policy
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed